this is not your typical car race
this is a race to make cars more like
computers and smartphones
and the best one to buy no it doesn't
stretch I don't want cameras anymore I
want map please slow down please don't
hit the Tesla that we rented are you
worried about dongles a little bit yeah
I spent the last month in search of the
perfect EV for me and my family that
meant testing five leading Options under
sixty thousand dollars over the course
of two months the Kia ev6 the Hyundai
ioniq 5 the Tesla Model y the Volkswagen
id4 and the Ford Mustang Mach e
after narrowing it down to three
finalists I took the remaining three on
a road trip to this racetrack to pick
the best one I evaluated them on four
features battery life charging
infotainment and semi-autonomous driving
and yes I factored in other important
stuff too including safety handling and
why do you like this car yo the farts
let's go
lap One battery life or what EV people
call range one of the biggest pieces of
criteria I had When selecting cars a
range of about 300 miles
to test I recruited two of my colleagues
and together we drove the three cars on
the same day under the same conditions
to the same destination
that destination Lime Rock racetrack in
Northern Connecticut 130 miles north of
my home in New Jersey
before we hit the road we made sure
every car was charged up
every car has to start at 100 and that
all the air conditioned levels were the
same each car was fairly new with
relatively low mileage to start Tesla
took the leaf about 30 miles into the
drive
what percentage are you at and how many
miles does it say you have left I have
94 and 278 miles I'm on 93 and 266 miles
the Hyundai however I mean 93
240 miles to be fair the Hyundai model I
tested was rated for around a 260 mile
range the company says its rear-wheel
drive model would have kept up here's
how that played out for the rest of the
two and a half hour drive after being on
the road for 75 miles Tesla and Ford
were neck and neck around 210 miles left
on the battery Hyundai was at 190. there
it is Lime Rock Park we did it
finally when we arrived at the track
both the Ford and Tesla had around 150
miles left to go Hyundai was still
behind still because all these cars can
be configured to hit a similar range
this lap is a it's a tie
lap two charging this is really where
these cars are like smartphones the
Tesla uses its own proprietary charging
connector and Port Apple it's called
lightning which now calls the North
American charging standard it also has
its own Tesla Chargers which are dead
simple to use after you've set up your
account in the app and
green
that's it Ford Hyundai and those other
cars I tested use the combined charging
system or CCS Port which work at
different charging stations from various
different companies and I found some of
those stations to be well unreliable
please work
but even when they do work I found that
there are some big issues with these
non-tesla stations which can all be
Illustrated in what happened in the
beautiful town of Falls Village
let me tell you a story about what
happened here last night
we realized that the cars were too low
to drive all the way home because we had
used them at the track a lot
I figured okay we'll charge them
overnight even though it's going to be
slow we met semiconnect our not very
good friend why would you be able to use
tap to pay no you've got to download
their proprietary app turns out
semiconnect was acquired by Blink so we
had to ultimately download another app a
blink spokesman told me that
semiconnect's transitioned to the blink
Network may have caused an inconvenience
for some users the company also plans to
add more Chargers with credit card
readers semiconnect was a slower charger
or a level 2 charger and it took roughly
six hours to charge the cars from 40
percent to a hundred percent all right
guys take care of each other
DC fast charging or what's sometimes
referred to as level 3 can do that in
under an hour and that's exactly what I
did with the Tesla on the road trip I've
consistently found it easier to find
Tesla fast Chargers called superchargers
especially in remote areas
the good news Tesla has agreed to allow
other cars from four GM and others to
access superchargers in early 2024 and I
think the winner here is pretty clear
the Tesla wins this round
lap three infotainment both Ford and
Tesla have similarly sized tablets that
have replaced pretty much all the
buttons knobs and dials okay Ford kept
this knob and this 10.2 inch screen
above the steering wheel so you can
easily see Vital Information like how
fast you're going with the Tesla I had
to look over to the right to see that
information Hyundai also has two screens
like the Ford this display here this is
teeny tiny compared to the Mustang and
to the Tesla feels like a display for
ants of course it's the software on
those screens that matters most
Tesla has its own software its
navigation system is built with Google
Maps data but it's not the Google Maps
app
the media apps like apple music and
Spotify are built in you just sign into
your account on the screen
play Fall Out Boy We Didn't Start the
Fire
[Music]
and you can pair your phone via
Bluetooth
Ford and Hyundai have their own software
as well which is not as good as Tesla's
what is this mess this whole navigation
feels like 1995. like a map quest
situation here but they also have
Android auto and Apple carplay
specifically Mustang has Wireless
carplay no wires check it out with the
Apple and Google software you do lose
some of that car and Battery integration
which really shines in the Tesla so as
soon as you route to a charger it will
say preconditioning battery for fast
charging the biggest decision I have to
make how badly do I want Apple carplay
2023 baby
no wires so yeah for this lap it's a tie
Tesla and Ford
lap four
semi-autonomous driving this is very
nerve-wracking when there's traffic
small breaths trusting Tesla with my
life right now all these cars have
active driving assistance features which
include adaptive cruise control and Lane
centering so the car can control the
speed and steering on a highway in the
Hyundai using these features requires
keep Hands-On steering wheel
but Ford and Tesla have more
capabilities in this area Ford's blue
Cruise prompts you to take your hands
off the wheel on highways oh God is it
gonna do it even for Lane changes you
just press on the turn signal and okay
it's preparing for another Lane change
all right it did it it did it Slow Down
slow down and it slowed down
when you enable Tesla's enhanced
autopilot it does tell you to keep your
hands on the wheel at first but in my
tests it behaved just like the Ford all
right let's see if it'll change lanes
up it's changing lanes oh boy okay that
is not as smooth as the
the Ford there's just one tiny question
to ask yourself here
which company are you going to trust
with your life
that is if you can actually trust the
computer to do the driving
Tesla has additional self-driving
features but I kept taking over the
wheel when testing them it's good enough
it's got enough
nope I got off I don't know if it was
going to get off I didn't trust it and I
did it overall I found Ford's blue
Cruise easier to figure out and more
informative and that's really what you
want in a situation where the computer
is your co-pilot it says Lane change is
not available right now
the board wins this round
as much as I like the Hyundai's exterior
look and Ultra fast battery charging
when I did find a fast charger it wasn't
going to be my next car but even after
that road trip and all that track
testing I didn't have a decision between
the Ford and the Tesla plus this really
did feel like a more emotional decision
than my next laptop or phone so I
decided to phone or Zoom a friend who
was reviewed more EVS on YouTube than I
could count hey I'm Marquez Brownlee AKA
MKBHD what would you consider if you
were deciding between these two cars I'm
not surprised that these are your two
final options are both really good I'd
be asking you questions like what are
you going to do with it I literally
don't recommend non-testly EVS to people
who actually road trip with any
regularity so if that's something you
plan on doing
more than a few times
it might be worth it just for that given
that this is a second car for my family
I don't expect I'd road trip more than
two to three times a year with the EV
plus I'm going to install a home charger
and next year Ford will be able to use
those Tesla Chargers but Marquez was
incredibly helpful in seeing the bigger
picture we saw the curve with phones go
like this
and then sort of even out and now
they're mature and they get a little
bump every year I think with cars we're
right here with electric cars we're at
the beginning so I should lease I leased
my first EV and I have no regrets about
that I think in three years your
computer on wheels will be much better
and that's what I've decided to do
Ford Mustang
Mach 36 months
because well I've always dreamed of
having a dongle to charge my car
[Music]
and that's the end of my game show